hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast emerging role of liquid
biopsies and NGS for biomarker discovery
I am Judy Aurora code lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by client hydrogen
in v.a Netherlands holding company is
relating global provider of sample and a
stage technologies that are used to
transform biological materials valuable
molecular information sample
technologies are used to isolate and
process DNA RNA and proteins from
biological samples such as blood or
tissue assay technologies are then used
to make these isolated biomolecules
visible and ready for interpretation
clients and markets more than 500
products around the world selling both
consumable tips and automation systems
to customers through for customer
classes molecular diagnostics in the
healthcare applied testing forensics
veterinary testing and food safety
pharma which is pharmaceutical and
biotechnology companies and academia is
life sciences research for your
information please visit www important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button the lower left of the
presentation window will try to get to
as many as we can and will follow up if
we don't have time today you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or a bit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like
introduce today's speaker Ryan samara
PhD
dr. Samara is a global product manager
for NGS technologies at client or the
focus on pre analytics and targeted
enrichment prior to joining quieten he
was a postdoctoral fellow at the
National Cancer Institute conducting
research in the field of cancer
immunology with emphasis on identifying
strategies to boost the efficacy of
cancer vaccine he received his PhD from
Georgetown University in tumor biology I
will now turn it over to dr. Samara for
his presentation thank you Judy and good
morning or good afternoon or good
evening everyone to today's webinar on
emerging role of liquid biopsies and
mgs4 biomarker discovery so just by way
of agenda these were different topics
that i would like to cover in today's
webinar first i'm going to go through a
background on but see for precision
medicine the next topic would be
addressing the challenges that are
associated biopsies and and how we could
use emphasis and then the third topic
would be how those liquid biopsies are
used on october an example from the
literature that have used NGS for
studying some mutations through liquid
biopsies and then close this webinar
with a summary in question so on two
quick brief background on liver biopsies
for precision medicine so when we think
of precision medicine we think of the
right drug for the right patient at the
right time and after like those this is
in contrast to what traditionally has
been done for for disease management
which is the one-size-fits-all approach
we know that the one-size-fits-all
approach does not work for everyone so
for instance if you look at the far left
on the left hand side i'm showing you
sort of a a brief description or what a
one-size-fits-all approach it looks like
so you have a patient or patients is
going to be prescribed a certain therapy
however because we do not really know
what the genetic background of that
patient is that patients might you know
you might see positive effect sorry you
might know effect
all or you might see adverse effects
with the precision medicine approach the
idea is to use the genetic information
from these patients in order to
prescribe certain therapies that will
only develop that will only give you
some positive effects and one of the
ways by which we can obtain this genetic
information is by liquid biopsies so
liquid biopsy is basically a biopsy that
we would take from fluid this could be
blood that could be serviced spinal
fluid it could be urine it could be any
type of liquid a liquid form that we can
get from from an individual and again
this is in contrast to solid biopsies
which are invasive and would take a lot
of time and and this comes for to to the
to the to the individual so liquid
biopsies are a great way are convenient
way to obtain this type of information
so what types of of genetic information
can we get from from individuals what
I'm showing you here are some DNA
variants that have been used for
precision medicine there are a lot of
DNA variants that can exist in any one
of us but the three haven't studied
excellent Aryans our point mutation
registry on the far left so with point
mutations you get a change in a
nucleotide and this change can actually
result in a constitutively active form
of a kinase for instance that they
report in the development of the breast
cancer another form of other variant is
the Andals insertions and deletions so
this is where you have certain
nucleotide be inserted into a strand of
DNA or sun sun nucleotide team we meet
and in the form of deletion and then you
also have copy number variants or
variations in with copy number
variations you get basically a
duplication or crepitation or so of a
specific gene so these are the three
sort of heavily studied types of
mutations but there are a lot of other
mutations like structural issues or
structural variants that could exist but
I'm not going to just I'm not going to
touch upon those today so why is this
information important this information
or
knowing this information or why is it
important this information is is very
useful because we can tell us a lot
about that in speed and my focus today
is going to be a lot on cancer just
because that's a topic that is near to
my heart so when we look at what you
know those different types of mutations
are they accumulate in in cancer
patients while those mutations are
detrimental in the sense that they
actually result in the development and
progress cancer we can ask to our
advantage we can use that that that
station and and develop and target that
specific mutation and obtain those
positive effects that I talked about
earlier so for instance if we look at
melanoma one of the one of the driver
mutations in melanoma is this BRF v600e
mutation this is a mutation that is
found in maybe more than fifty or sixty
percent of melanoma patients so while
this mutation is actually going to drive
the development and progression of
melanoma we can actually target this
this specific mutation with a drug
called them raffinate so the maratha
name was developed to specifically
tackle those melanoma cases have these
600e mutations an example of how we can
use instant and deletion information for
our tour advantage for precision
medicine is the egfr deletions and in
London one diagonal carcinomas so a lot
of tyrosine kinase inhibitors have been
developed to tackle these types of DNA
variants and then finally for tati
number variations the best example that
I can sync up for copy number variations
is her to sew her to is is amplified in
certain forms of breast cancer and again
while this amplification is going to
drive the development and progression of
breast cancer its presence or the
duplication of obsession of her to can
actually be targeted by a monoclonal
antibody that has been developed and
it's called trastuzumab or Herceptin so
so again while these types of variants
are detrimental because they can lead to
the development and progression of
cancer we can
actually now develop drugs and target
those specific mutations and achieve
those positive effects through precision
medicine so how many actionable DNA
variants are there and what I mean by
actionable DNA variants are those DNA
variants that we can take action against
again in this example of the DRF v600e
mutation if that mutation is present we
know we can target it with that specific
blood but if we look at the total number
of actionable DNA virulent are there I
would argue that there are only a
handful of DNA variants so you might end
up with you know for specific disease
maybe tens or so of these action will be
actionable DNA variants we all have DNA
variants in our DNA whether you know
whether you're regardless of of the of
the ethnic background or so there are a
lot of variants that exists within us so
you have all these common variants right
and then you have a lot of variants that
might develop but they do not have any
obvious effect on approach so they're
just through them like passenger
mutations they we don't really know what
they do and then then if you take if you
go through that so playing process and
end up with those with those mutations
or variants that are not common that
seem to have a obvious effect on a
protein but then you still have to study
those types of there and then understand
what they do from a biological and
clinical perspective through this
iterative biological interpretation step
so once you studied several variants you
might end up with only a very handful
number of variants that through
biological interpretation actually show
that they can they can contribute to the
development installation of cancer as
you go through all these filtering
processes what you end up where there's
probably only 10 or purchase be relevant
and actionable variants and again
examples of those variants were the you
know be rasa v600e mutation me the
amplification of her too and so on and
so forth so there's really a very very
limited number of DNA variants that we
can access
so just to give you an example so this
is this is data that that I adapted from
a paper that was published in fell back
in 2012 and it looked at the current
lung cancer biomarker lasted so when I
say current that goes right two twenties
but however this much so within this
paper what the were the authors did they
wanted to understand the types of
mutations and the percentage of these
mutations that accumulate in one cancer
patients and so what you see here is
really the percentage of of patients
shall we be specific types of mutations
so for instance the authors show here
that 25 of lung cancer patients
accumulating mutations in the K ration
and then you have a three percent of
simulating mutations in the egfr gene
and so on and so forth and then you have
thirty-seven percent of them with an
unknown mechanism right so you have the
you have a still a large a large number
of patients where where we do not really
know where to cause it now but but the
point is if you look at the types of or
the number of genes you might end up
with maybe five or six or seven of them
for lung cancer um when we look at the
lung cancer biomarker landscape so again
a handful of genes that are important
for this specific type of cancer now
this important this information is
important because it allows us to
understand the underlying mechanisms of
lung cancer but it is also important
from a therapeutic perspective so when
when those are at patients with a
citation in egfr known as the l85a2
fornication the authors show that these
types of we take these types of patients
with this mutation they achieve a good
response rate when they are treated with
tyrosine kinase inhibitors so these are
the air lot in it and just sit in it
tyrosine kinase inhibitors that I
mentioned earlier so you have this you
have you have a patient or individual
with this type of mutation they get
prescribed these tires and kinase
inhibitors you see a really good
response rate however this response
rates now drop if the same individual
has a mutation in
hey Russ gene in the form of G 12c so
the the addition or or the the presence
of this of this one mutation only is
going to now drop the response rate
students tyrosine kinase inhibitors
showing you that it is it is still very
crucial to understand what types of
mutations if you really want to take
advantage of the precision medicine
approach we really need to know what
types of mutations are present in these
individuals and that the only these
mutations does not help us understand
the underlying cause of this disease but
it also going to help us in managing
this disease and the in the example that
i'm going to show you from with it from
the literature later on you'll also see
how additional types of mutations can
mediate resistance to therapy so again
it's not only to understand the relief
not only for prescribing and therapy but
it's also it also helps us understand
also how resistance to certain therapies
can develop in these patients so but
then the question is how do you test for
these mutations from there are two way
two major ways to to test for these
mutations you can test for them
sequentially or you can spare them in a
parallel manner eventually means that it
has 4k recitations first for egfr again
for be less entation third and so on and
so forth now while well a lot of these
approaches are very sensitive and the
amount of time it takes if you want to
do sequential testing is a long time I
mean if you think of a day for chaos
testing a day for egfr testing it should
take you a week or so if you want to go
through all of those mutations that are
known to contribute your lung cancer
this is opposed as opposed to parallel
peso your thorough testing you're
looking at all of these restrictions at
the same time and that is where the
power of NGS comes in because we could
use now a technology that allows us to
look at all of these mutations not just
in one sample but also in a lot of
sample simultaneously it cuts down the
cost and time associated with new stuff
successfully so do my focus match is
going to be on n gs and how NGS or
next-generation sequencing can be used
for
for the testing of all the fermentation
in liquid biopsy samples now the idea of
liquid biopsy for precision medicine has
existed for a while this is the lead in
one paper that i can think of that
really took a census of a liquid biopsy
approach forever non-invasive way to
identify and monitor communications by
mgs it's a big fidelis published in
science translational medicine back in
2012 and what the authors hear from from
the UK did is that they used liquid
biopsy to to accomplish three major
objectives first is to screen for and
identify more frequency mutations as low
as to person so when you think our
principal cancer samples you always
think of heterogeneity associated with
each sample heterogeneity means that you
will find you your you want and you
won't end up with a homogeneous
population of cells that that share all
the genetic information together what
you end up with is a mix of cells that
have and each one of these cells has its
own sort of genetic signature and that's
what i mean by hydrogenation so when you
look at the sample in its entirety the
driver mutation because they're not
going to exist in all of the cells
because they did the exogenous
population those those driver mutations
might end up being two percenters three
percent or even one percent of your
sample so that's what i mean by
low-frequency mutation and the second
objective was to non-invasively identify
the origin of matrix metastatic relapse
in a patient with multiple primary tumor
so again they use that information to
understand the underlying mechanism of
the development of CDs and they also the
third objective we wanted to monitor
tumor dynamics by tracking ten mutations
in plasma of a metastatic breast cancer
patient over 16 months so again this
shows you the power of using a liquid
and liquid biopsy biopsy approach with
liquid biopsies you can take I don't
want to say as many biopsies as you like
but it is much easier to obtain a liquid
biopsy spent to explain assaulted by C
so you can actually use that biopsy to
type of ice by
now to monitor the progress and much
more effectively and efficiently than
than by using the dissolved by us to
approach so how do you how can you
examine those genetic variants by mgs
there are three very high-level sort of
levels of NGS you have the whole genome
sequence there folks you have the whole
exome sequencing approach and many
others DNA sequencing approach now which
level cities of the physics is where you
will see first so in the Holy folks
you're getting a very high burden so
think of you know think of yourself and
a flying a helicopter or plane and
you're just looking at this looking at
the very top this for the force with a
whole exome sequencing approach what
you're what you're trying to do is to
instead of getting this very high level
view you're getting a high level right
so instead of just see the top of those
please now what you're starting you're
starting to see more detail about about
that force you actually feel the crunch
of those trees not just me not just for
me with a targeted DNA sequencing
approach you're actually looking at how
those tongues look okay so you're
getting a deeper view of that force and
with targeted DNA sequencing you're
getting a deeper view into that into
that DNA sample now how do they differ
so what I've tried to do here is to
compare the three different see person
levels on different parameters and up
and attributes so first on information
level with a whole genome sequencing
approach you're looking at everything
right so you're looking at every single
base that exists in that DNA sample
there you're studying with a whole exome
sequencing approach you're looking only
at those those regions that code for
jeans so you know you shrunk your genome
down to those regions that that will
code for protein with a targeted DNA
sequencing approach you as a user or
researcher you're going to define what
regions you want to look at those
reasons can be yeah they can be gene
from certain exon junkie they can be in
transportation promoter regions how
were you as a researcher however you
define that sort of information level so
it is much more tailored to what you
want to do now when we look at cost for
sample the the three-level differ
dramatically while we are all striving
for that one thousand-dollar genome cost
we're not there yet so when we look at
because of doing the whole genome
sequencing on a sample it's still talked
about five thousand dollars so all
numbers numbers in the US I know that
you know they will vary depending on
where you are but but but but I would
say the numbers are very fairly close to
each other so we're still at the you
know more than thousand dollars for and
you know and even when we look at annex
own a sequencing experiment it's so
costs a lot of money it would cost about
two thousand dollars if you want to get
sequence to excellent in that sample
with a targeted DNA sequencing approach
then brought that part down to maybe two
hundred dollars simply because you are
narrowing down your the region that has
to be sequence and by net without those
region what you could do is you can
multiplex many samples simultaneously
which means you can actually sequin many
samples for we find all on the same run
so think about it this way if you are
spending a thousand dollars or two
thousand dollars for sequencing reagents
on a sequencing platform but you are
able to analyze a hundred samples
simultaneously you take that 22,000
fired by by a hundred samples your cost
for samples only twenty dollars so that
is really the power of NGS also it's
just that ability to look at many
samples simultaneously and examine many
different mutations at the same time so
the other attribute is the detective low
frequency mutations so so remember I i
mentioned i mentioned this earlier when
I talked about the the low frequency
mutation then in the metro genius
samples so again when you're dealing
with with these types of heterogeneous
samples you are going to be looking at
some mutations that are present at low
frequencies and it is important to
those types of mutations because a lot
of those low frequency mutations are the
ones that are driving that the
progression and development of cancer
now so the question is which which
sequencing level can you use in order to
check those low frequency mutations with
a whole genome approach the depth of
sequence that you get from a whole
genome approach is not going to be
enough to look at those lovely low
frequency mutations with an exome
sequencing approach maybe you might get
enough depth to to examine some of these
types of mutations but with a targeted
DNA sequencing approach again because
you are restricting the sequencing to
certain genes or certain regions in the
genome you're getting a lot more depth
of coverage what I mean by depth of
coverage is just the number of times
each basic sequence and this is
extremely important if you're looking at
low frequency mutation you want to get
as high as coverage as possible in order
to accurately examine those low
frequency mutation so with a targeted
DNA sequencing approach yes you can look
at these low frequency mutations now
slightly look add also the DNA inputs to
how much DNA do you need and also the
number of samples multiplexed you see a
huge variation between or differences
between these three approaches for DNA
if you're using a whole genome
sequencing approach you need you need
one microgram or so so so this this
could be a limiting for some sample like
FFC is coupled if you're trying to
analyze genetics you know the DNA
isolated from FFPE samples you might not
be able to do a whole genome sequencing
approach with a whole exome this drops
down to between 100 to 200 mammogram but
with a targeted DNA sequencing approach
you can go avoid 10 milligrams per
reaction so you're using a lot less DNA
which actually saves you saves most of
that sample if you want to use it for
other study and it also facilitates the
the analysis of those samples that do
not yield a whole lot of DNA like liquid
biopsies and you're not going to get
micrograms of DNA from a liquid biopsy
you might get 10 nanograms 29 aground or
so depending on whether it's a helping
or or or disease individual so so the
amount of DNA drops dramatically also
the number of samples when we look at
the number multiplied again this is the
number of sample they can run
simultaneously in the same reaction the
whole genome approach you might I mean I
don't think you can be too in the same
reaction so all of that cost five
cylinder is going to be used for only
one sample from you look at a whole
exome sequencing approach you have you
can maybe multiplex to when you look at
a targeted DNA sequencing approach you
can multiplex up to 96 or even more
depending again depending on how many
samples you have and what kind of depth
feel looking for but the idea here is
that you can you can run many samples
simultaneously if you're using a target
again be person approach which again
drives your costs down I'm seeing some
tremendous for the sake of time if you
can hang on till this to remember we'll
get to all of these questions eyes upon
I'm service so what are the benefits of
targeted DNA sequencing it gives you
more relevant data because you are you
are defining the region they want to
look at it is more cost effective again
because you have the ability to do this
higher multiplexing approach your costs
are going to be decreased and then it's
the ability to detect low-frequency
mutations again these are mutations that
could be extremely important from a
biological and clinical perspectives and
more DNA required okay so why choose a
targeted DNA sequencing approach it
gives you well defined content so you
are you as a researcher you are defining
the content you can shrink that genome
to smaller type it sizes this allows you
to not sex any samples save money and it
gives you more reads per sample so it
gives you more coverage and this allows
you to be sexual frequency so just
you're going to put this into in a in a
graphical format the idea is to again
shrink that genome down to those jeans
that you are interested in so if you're
interested in studying only tilak egfr
and I bh1 it makes sense to use a
targeted in which
approach to shrink that genomic DNA that
you isolated from from a liquid biopsy
or or any other sample it makes sense to
shrink that down three only those three
genes and so that when you do your
analysis and sequencing you're only at
sequencing and analyzing those fitting
jeans and looking at the mutations that
are present in those three genes again
this is this is an approach that can be
extremely helpful if you have a lot of
samples or if you if you do not want to
know a whole lot about your sample right
so again this goes back to the number of
DNA variants actionable DNA variants
that are present there are a lot of
variants that whose function we have no
idea what what what it does right so
there could be a mutation in I don't
know Eckstein for v-necks that that has
been seen in a couple of cases and and
we really do not know what it does so if
you if you're only interested in looking
at the be actionable being a decision
the targeted DNA sequencing approach can
be a very very useful technique so what
are the challenges associated with a
liquid biopsy there are several
challenges the three main ones is the
load DNA quality the load many quantity
and the low variant allele frequency I
kind of alluded to those in in previous
slide but I just kind of want to dig
deeper into those challenges in this
content now so looking at the load DNA
quality we know that the DNA that you
get from liquid biopsies from is heavily
fragmented so you're not getting intact
DNA you have you might have bits and
pieces of many floating around and
because it is highly fragmented you want
to you want to restrict the the way you
sequence your those those be an aid to
short short library fragments now there
are two ways by which you can do the
enrichment part you can do multiplex pcr
or hybridization based approach we
wanted to take advantage of these high
specificity and unix ability of pcr so
we developed a malicious based approach
it takes again it takes advantage of the
specifically and uniformity of of pcr
this is AG
we a there was a nice comparison between
the different targeted enrichment
approaches it was a paper published in
nature message back in 2010 and it
really it nicely consents targeted
enrichment approaches that you could use
if you want to enrich for specific
regions or specific genes in your DNA
and it basically that one of their
conclusions would that be specific
immunity of CCR cannot be matched by any
other method and that's valid the basis
for for for our products we wanted to
take advantage of PCR because of the
high specificity game uniformity and the
way plays multiplex PCR works is is
actually very simple if let's take an
example here a poor for g1 and g2 let's
call those arrested media for the idea
is to design primers against chaos and
egfr as you see in those arrows so these
arrows represent primers that have been
designed to to allow you to amplify egfr
and arrest these could be primers
against all the exons in these 2 g's or
could we it could be climbers against
certain regions within those two genes
and then you take those primers and you
just put them into an appropriate number
of CPR for that could be one two three
or four again depending on how many how
many primers you have and how far apart
those primers are that that have been
designed to target being the region's
you are interested in so again take
those those jeans we want climbers
against those those jeans or those
regions and then flip them into an
appropriate number of pcr for that is
the idea of a multiplex PCR based
approach but of course you have to
develop also the the associated keeps
our chemistry that allows you to amplify
those those to those 20 region so that
you know looking at multiplex PCR it is
just primers against certain gene now
the trick is by how do you design those
primers because if you think of this
folks you might end up with thousands of
primer pairs in the same reaction right
so so primer design is an extremely
extremely innocent parameter to think of
when you're looking at multiplex PCR
based approaches
so but again the idea is that you take
that genomic DNA you mix it with the
primers and the PTR chemistry and what
you end up with are these double strand
amplicon that represent your genes of
interest so again going back to this
example of K refugia for idh1 if you're
only interested in these jeans and you
want to use a multiplex pcr based
approach what's what you do is design
primers against all the three genes and
then take those primers mix mix them
with your with the genomic DNA this is
unfragmented or unprocessed you know
making in the sense that you do not need
to fragment it anymore it's already
fragmented because it's from the foot
biopsies right so so you take those
primers mix them with the genomic DNA
and a few our chemistry and where you
end up with all these amplicons like
these double-stranded pieces that you
see and red purple yellow and green so
these now Albert ron's represent your
genes of interest so the way we have
developed those applicants is to
generate we wanted them to be around 150
based stairs inside this is this is a
small price compared to other larger
fragments and dividing to keep them
small is because of a fragment of the
liquid biopsy of the DNA that you get
from liquid biopsy if you use longer
applicants these longer amplicons might
not work efficiently with fragmented DNA
so again because of that challenge you
have to have a solution that allows you
to generate small amplicons and that's
what we have done with the Gojira panels
that we have developed using multiplex
pcr based approaches so low quantity so
you're not going to get my programs of
DNA from your sample so you need a
solution that allows you to use you know
very small amounts of DNA for target in
Richmond with with a solution that we
have developed for Tristan Thompson
you're only using ten nanograms per
tutti are for so remember that you pick
those primers and flip them into an
appropriate number of pcr pools if you
end up with let's say two pool you need
to nanograms we've seen a total of
twenty nanograms DNA which is something
that security looking at liquid biopsies
sample patient that is something that
you can easily achieve the other
challenge is the ability to look at low
frequency very until your frequencies so
so again this goes back to the idea of a
heterogeneous the heterogeneous samples
that I mentioned previously you're
looking at mutations that are not every
single cell so what you end up with in
your sample is this frequency any DNA
mutation that our president of low
frequencies now in order to address this
challenge what we have done is we've
taken sort of unique amplicon designs or
approaches design approaches so what I'm
showing you here is the way our
applicants would look like if you're if
you're specifically looking at let's say
zanjeer probe locus of krad so this is
again this is a motive that is heavily
mutated in cancers and in order to to
make sure that you see that specific
locus in your samples the way we've
designed the app and if you look at the
blue bars here the blue bars represent
amplicon that will be generated from the
actionable mutations panel for instance
you see what call a week or redundant
piling up row so you see a lot of
applicants that cover that specific
locus and the idea is we want to ensure
their best specific voltage look it's
covered in your sample and the way we do
this is by designing multiple amplicon
so in case one of the amplicons drops
out for whatever reason in the PCR
reaction on the pcr set up you still
have three applicants covering a
specific locus so going to ensure that
that those those actionable mutations
that I talked about earlier are actually
covered in your liquid biopsies
another another important feature to or
challenged actually for liquid biopsies
and looking at appleton sequencing is
the ability to protect the end of
amplicons so when anyone was I've seen
will realize that the last two or three
basis of an amplicon do not actually get
sequence very efficiently it's just the
nature or the sequencers that we that we
have currently on the market in order to
protect those ends what you need to you
need to keep the primer sequences at the
ends of those applicants in order to
protect those last two or three basis of
your applicant so by doing so by keeping
the primer sequences and actually
sequencing those primer sequences what
you end up missing are the two or three
bases of the primer sequence itself and
this is this these are sequences that
you will not be using anyways for your
variance calling step you will only be
using this for for the for mapping and
alignment so by keeping the primer
sequence in fact two ends of the
amplicons you are actually protecting
the the the end of those fragments that
you want to sequence right and this is
extremely important because we end up
with less it is again if you think of
the situation where you do not have
primer sequences you will end up missing
those two to three basis of our vet
fragment and if there are important
variants present in those at the ends of
those of those fragments you're not
going to be able to see them resulting
in false negative so this this feature
is extremely important if you're looking
at low frequency mutation and this is
actually very nicely described in a
paper published fig back in 2014 yes in
BMC genomics and it is specifically
addressed this or this construct and
there was another paper that actually
looked at also the benefits of having or
keeping the the primer sequences event
of a perk on it's a paper that was
published this year in the NC cancer and
they basically what they did they wanted
to compare two different approaches for
multiplex PCR one that digests awfully
the the primer sequences from from the
app
times and then the hydrophobics does not
digest off the primer sequences and when
they were the results in there in terms
of sensitivity and specificity of those
a say they were seeing that the the
other multiplex pcr based approach is
delivering 93% sensitivity whereby five
mutations out of 74 our next and the
reason those five mutations were mrs.
because they were present at the
amplicon boundaries so again these are
the two or three bases at the end zone
photons that will be missed if you do
not have primer sequences okay so
another another challenge is the number
of or the different types of sequencers
reading this on the market so you know
if you look at illumina alumina has a
lot of sequences on the market then you
have the Ion Torrent sequencers and
other sequences as well so the having
having all these different options
complicates the sample processing steps
so what we have done here is to to have
this Universal approach so the same
panel can actually be news on different
different platforms whether it's an
platform from alumina or a platform for
mind-tour into the platform independent
solution we types of panels that we have
developed married but they address
different different applications from
solid tumors 3d mythological species
tissue specific approaches and even
gene-specific approaches like black
aluminum bracket tools and even a more
comprehensive approach likely
comprehensive cancer panel the content
of these panels comes from different
rekha basis like we cancer genome atlas
immensity and from cosmic from from
nature reviews from for even passed by
the databases like the ingenuity
databases so we've drawn on the content
from all these different databases for
you notice it and put fall that conflict
into specific channels that makes sense
for different applications now if you do
not like the patent for whatever reason
you can build your own customized
channels or there are two ways to build
these customized paneled either through
the mix-and-match offering or the custom
offering through the mix-and-match
offering you get access to all those
gene design that we have
it in-house or there's about 570 bench
tested game design so you can build your
panels from those 570 bench tested gene
design or if it's something that does
not exist we do not within those 570 you
can go through system offering and that
way you basically build you know the
panel that that that is specific to your
needs and again through this custom
offering you can you can build panels
for jeans you can build panels for exons
for influence for promoter region any
region that you can that you can think
of a wonder that as well annotated with
in this image you know okay just to kind
of give you the example of the tower of
mix and match these are gene designs
that we have tested in house those g
designs are going to behave similar
similarly regardless of the panel that
they exist in so if i look at the gene
designed for the neck g it is present in
four different panels from the
tissue-specific panels to the more
comprehensive cancer panel and when we
look at the specificity and uniformity
of those of the of the meta the message
in design we know that it is delivering
high specific and uniform extent
regardless of the panel and richard
exist again because the gene designs
have been optimized stood in a house so
just for the sake of sign I think I've
mentioned all of this all of these
features previously oh the one thing
that I did not mention is that you end
up with with one library per sample so
we can our work fully pull all of our
applicant coming out of the sample after
the after the enrichment steps so he's
going into library construction you only
end up with one library per sample as
opposed to ending up with multiple
libraries for sample which stage save a
lot of times there's a lot of money ok
for that analysis just to briefly talk
talk about the Deaf analysis this is
also a major challenge with with mgs and
liquid biopsies there are several tools
that exist out there to try them you can
get access to a lot of databases and a
lot of solutions through the CLC by
offering for
for analysis of NGS data and then we
ingenuity a databases as well as bio
base if you want to look at if you want
to interpret what draws variants in so
so you've detected certain variants in
your sample what does it mean from a
biological and clinical standpoint to
see those variants so I'm not I want to
fit those for the favor just kind of
quickly go through this the field feed
by pipeline allow you to or pipeline
allows you to build your own algorithms
or by by constructing these different
windows so you define how you want to
map your when you define how you want to
call the variants and so on and so forth
and for each of use there is a plug-in
for the gene region a cpanel that I
mentioned I'm just kind of make amplicon
based analysis much easier the ingenuity
databases is a really powerful tool to
allow you to again make sense of that
data so then you've seen those variants
what are the EU from a biological and
clinical standpoint now so if when we
look when we think of the targeted DNA
sequencing approach we see it heavily
bereaved and clinical and translational
research and again for these different
types of research areas you know you do
need different content so for the
clinical research where you want a high
degree of detection we've developed
these very small panels the actionable
mutations and clinically relevant panel
to allow you to achieve this very high
degree of detection and allow you to
also multiplex many examples together if
you're interested in the translational
side of research be more comprehensive
panels make more sense because they
allow you to do some discovery the
ability to detect lower frequency
mutation drops compared to the smaller
panels but also it allows you to do some
stories and because the target size is a
little larger than the actionable
mutations and clinically relevant panel
your ability to multiplex drops as well
now these panels although you are
restricting your your area of interest
you can still use those types of panels
for mutation discovery here's a paper
that was published in
Nature Genetics back in 2014 actually
used a very small panel but that panel
facilitated the identification of the
new bracket to mutation the selenium 960
patient so you can still use smaller
panels to do some you know some form of
discovery and also the clinical value
has been questioned the clinical value
of a targeted DNA sequencing approach
has been questioned however there are
multiple multiple papers out there that
actually show you that it's that it's
extremely important to look at those low
frequency variance by a targeted DNA
sequencing approach this is a paper that
was published in 2014 by by in the
Journal of Clinical Oncology and
actually only use a whole panel to look
at black or Nebraska mutation and they
say that the results that they received
from that small panel prompted
consideration of a change in clear so so
again we can still use a focus type of
an approach to 44 disease management so
just to kind of give you an example of
how those how a liquid biopsy approach
can be used I fix a paper that was
published in Nature Medicine but this
will give you a little bit of background
about the paper and they're approached
so they're focused on one cancer are the
authors are focused on on lung cancer
and we know that egfr mutant lung cancer
so you got lung cancer specimens that
that have mutations easier for people
that they are sensitive to those egfr
tyrosine kinase inhibitors as I've shown
previously however over time we know
that there are a lot of the patient that
that will accumulate that mediates
resistance to be tyrosine kinase
inhibitors and this is an example this
is beta come from a paper published in
2011 and it actually looked at the
mechanism of of a resistance to these
parasitic Chinese competitive and we
commonly see mutation that mediates
resistance the tyrosine kinase
inhibitors in lung cancer is this t790m
mutation is therefore so what
researchers have done is they's you know
they've developed certain drugs
target the streets of the 90 a mutation
the idea is if you see this mutation
being developed as a resistance to the
first class of tyrosine kinase
inhibitors why not develop a second
class that specifically targets t790m
and this has been a very successful
story there are multiple blood now that
targets this type of mutation for lung
cancer with some very good results
however knowing how cancer to behave
most likely they will develop even more
resistance mutations resistance to that
second class of tyrosine kinase
inhibitors so with this paper the one
that I mentioned earlier the authors
wanted to answer this question can we
identify potential mechanisms of
resistance to 89 to 91 which is a drug
that with targeting the teacher the
ninth wheel a mutation before the time
before the other availability of
resistance file system between can we
identify and so resistance mechanisms
before we can actually get a solid tumor
before we actually see those resistance
developed in the form of another solid
tumor so they what they wanted to do is
to take a look good biopsy approach and
the paper again was published in Nature
Medicine in May so they wanted to take a
liquid biopsy approach using a review
read targeted mgs panels on cell free
DNA and these were this was this was a
sample that are taken from a phase on
clinical trial idea to attend we
kontagious pogchamp to process them and
features the DNA that we from those
blood samples and look at what types of
mutations accumulate in in these in
these in these patients and try to
identify the mutations that could
mediate resistance to that second class
of tyrosine kinase inhibitors so their
approach was fairly simple they
collected blood they prepared plasma
they isolated cells managers in papaya f
circulating the playback kit they
enriched 20 g we were these that are
heavily implicated in one console using
the gene leave benefits one cancer panel
they constructed library
or you still see me I don't know if we
lost the connection i get a note that
there was a failure to reconnect but i'm
still getting anything good okay hold on
okay great so they constructed libraries
for a high seat and then they did with
ultra deep sequencing getting up to
30,000 x between that all those jeans
all those fun jeans were sleeping thirty
thousand times basically right using
this high slit this is a powerful
sequence source of property to actually
get up to those those on that level of
coverage and again this type of coverage
is extremely important if you're looking
at low frequency mutations you might not
need to go up to 30,000 x but because
they're using liquid biopsies they
wanted to ensure that every single base
in there get sequence many many times
okay so what did they see so as a proof
of concept they just wanted to look at
5am example at baseline and progression
a fly means arm you know when when when
the patients first entered the clinical
trials and progression once i started
seeing some some some resistance for
against me these tyrosine kinase
inhibitors so you see when you look at
the types of mutation they look at the
key 790 a mutation which is present in
baseline and under progression
conditions because those patients were
known to have this seat 790 a mutation
right so the drug that they are crying
is against have been developed identity
for the 90 a mutation so you expect to
have a patient in there however when
when the researchers looked at samples
under progression condition they started
seeing the sea 797 FC mutation that they
saw under progression conditions that
they would not they were not seeing this
at that baseline which means that this
mutation has actually developed over
over time after the the those patients
were treated with this second class type
of person kinase inhibitor so this will
just as a proof of concept they wanted
to identify what mutations that could be
seen in in patients that develop
resistance to that
class tyrosine kinase inhibitor and to
take it one step further they swim many
more many more samples and started
looking at the mutations that are
present in the tumor itself and in the
endoplasmic samples and again they were
comparing baseline and in progression so
again in the tumor and plasma you still
see this t790m mutation again something
that's expected because these patients
always have the sensation now when
looking at the the other mutations that
some developed specifically the c7 my
side and X mutation they started seeing
this mutation accumulate under
progression condition in both the tumor
and the plasma which and the idea here
was to tend tend attended plasma samples
accurately tell you what is happening in
the tumor so for the sea sediments of
intestine tation it clearly tells you
what is actually happening in the tomb
one could be used as a surrogate to to
look at the mechanisms of resistance in
the chamber itself because you see now
the sweet side amounts of an ethnic
ation in the plugin samples under
progression conditions as you see it's
in the tumor samples under progression
conditions and not only did they see
this key to a mutation that results in
the seats of the 97 s mutation but they
were also seeing some other types of
mutations in the same locus that will
result in this seat 797 3797 s mutation
but it was it was a difference lunch
instead of looking and sort of thing
that c2 a change they receive a key to
see change in the same locus so not only
are you seeing changes in the amino acid
but it seems that the underlying all of
this change is also different or is sort
of is developing in these types of of
resistance mechanisms so just to close
this off summary and question so it's
all going to be an a sequencing enabled
precision medicine using the liquid
biopsy approach target DNA sequencing
can be used to detect low-frequency
mutation this last example clearly shows
that you can go down to maybe one
percent or so of mutation frequency in
your sample but again you need to
very powerful sequencers and very
powerful bus but informatics tools in
order to achieve this now click on base
enrichment using multiplex PCR delivered
the high level of specificity and
uniformity that are that are required to
overcome the low quality and quantity of
the liquid biopsy be in it so again you
get you don't have a whole lot of DNA to
begin with and the DNA the isolates is
of low quality because it's highly
segmented you need a method that is very
specific and very uniform in order to
look at these types of of variance in
your liquid biopsy samples redundant and
overlapping appleton designing delivers
the deep coverage required for detecting
low-frequency mutations now if you're
looking at those low frequency decreases
we also want to ensure that they get
covered adequately and having this over
laughing and rebuild it excuse me
redundant design ensures that they get
recovered and liquid biopsies are an
efficient way to monitor duty
progression and resistance that last
example was really very powerful in
sewing showing us how you can actually
use with the biopsies to monitor
defeated so with that I think you can
get two questions right now to thank you
all for joining and let's get to the
questions thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is how different is this
approach then capture based methods for
enrichment and which approach should I
you um so so the there are two major
ways by which you can enrich for your
jeans first of the multiplex pcr and the
capture based approach the main
difference is the specificity and
uniformity so with the multiplex PCR
based approach you get a very high level
of specificity for and uniformity
something that you cannot get with
capture based approaches but the main
advantage of a capture based approach is
is when you have large targets so if you
have like let's say 300
or 400 gene that we consider as large
targets then the hybridization or the
capture based approach might be more
appropriate multiplex pcr be very
powerful very highly specific and
uniform if you're looking at you know
maybe less than 200 genes so that's
that's where that's when that's when I
would use the multiplex pcr based
approach if I have something you know
300 400 genes or so i would need to
capture those approach what types of
variance community exhibition Richmond
approach and is this perfume in DNA only
so the types of variance with this
approach we can look at point mutations
or snips we can look at small insertions
and deletions something that is less
than 40 basis or so as well as copy
number variation so we cannot look at
structural changes in DNA using this
approach and then what we've developed
here is yes for human DNA on can I build
a panel for hot spots only yes you can
sew through the 3d custom are offering
you can actually define your target the
way you want you can define the targets
at exxon you can define them as only
specific hot spots within those Exxon or
influence you can define in chronic
regions you can define promoter regions
so you can we can use that approach to
define whatever reason you want
including hot spots like depth of
coverage to your rack end there or is
this just the answer is going to depend
on what types of mutations you're
looking at if you're looking at drumline
mutations I person there's only my
personal recommendation I would
recommend 200x are for coverage if
you're looking at somatic mutations like
the ones that we see in cancer i would
recommend up to 1,500 excess mean
coverage how much DNA can i get from a
liquid biopsy um so it's going to vary
depending on the disease state right so
if you're if you're if you're getting a
liquid biopsies from a healthy
individual you might not get a whole lot
of DNA from
from a liquid vibes maybe a total of
size 2 10 mammogram that most but if you
were if you're looking at or if you're
if you're using it a biopsy that has
been pasted from let's say a patients
with advanced cancer you're going to end
up with a lot more DNA so you might end
up with 30 to 40 nano grams from from
the liquid biopsy it looks like we may
have time for just one more question are
there differences of the results of the
mutations profile went from one patient
different liquid biopsies of origin can
be chicken for example blood and urine
sample so will there be different in of
the result mutational profile so that's
that is a good question and it it will
be different now I don't have the I
don't have an example here from the
literature but but but the the
difference you're going to see
differences depending on the sample that
you use if you use a liquid a solid
biopsy a biopsy dating that's taken from
the tumor itself versus looking at
mutation that that are associated with
that humor from urine or from what you
are going to see differences because
you're not going to get the complete
mutational profiles is present in that
first in that in that solid tumor right
the the mutation that you see in blood
or urine is going to depend on the
ability of humor to shed those to set
those those DNA fragments basically in
the circulation so if the poor is not
able to release DNA into circulation you
might not see those mutations in your
liquid biopsies so that's where the
defense's could come could come from but
there will be differences in the
different liquid biopsies depending on
again whether you can collect the DNA
whether the DNA has been shed from the
tumor and how powerful your sequencing
approaches to look at these conclusions
I would once again like to thank dr.
Samara for his presentation do you have
any final comments to share with us
today dr. smara oh well just as a final
comment give you a liquid biopsy
approach using mgs to look at mutations
is approach that is becoming more and
more popular but I would definitely say
that it has its limitations it's not
it's not for every single tumor it's not
for every single case and you know it's
the amount of DNA that you get is a
challenge the quality of DNA that you
get to the challenge so if you really
want to use a liquid biopsy approach you
know just make sure that you have the
the powerful tool sequence and the
powerful tools to to prepare your sample
and also the powerful tools to examine
your results thank you I'd also like to
thank our sponsor clients for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through april one 2016
you'll receive an email from lab groups
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
may have missed today's live event see
you next time